can a theorist really make progress the
answer is no a theorist can't do
anything can't do crap by themselves
sitting in a room because for a very
important reason you may think it is the
job of a of an experimental physicist
like me or a theoretical physicist to
prove something uh but actually proof in
physics is completely impossible any
physical science is impossible there's
only two subjects you can prove
something in one is called logic or
philosophy and the other is math math
can actually have a theorem like 1+ 1
equals 2 it will take 200 pages to prove
it from different you know category
Theory group Theory set theory and you
can prove it multiple ways you could
prove Pythagorean theorem and I think
300 different ways you can prove it but
you can't prove a Theory of physics
right if I say the um evolution is true
all I have to do is find one counter
counter I'm not saying this exists of
lamari and genetic traits and actually
some of it you know was was thought to
be very plausible say or that you know
you find some type of creature that
doesn't use DNA and only uses RNA or
some triple I I'm making it up but but
the point is one counter example can
falsify something that was previously
believed to be true like Newtonian
gravity like einsteinian gravity we
don't even think Einstein's the final
word right there's no final word because
there's no proof in physical science
there's only proof in a mathematical
abstract abstruse sense as it is say in
mathematics and and in in philosophy so
for physicists it gives them great angst
theoretical physicists know that not
only is it not possible for their Theory
to be proven it may not even be testable
and this is the problem with theories
like that of people like MCH okaku Brian
green or Edward Whitten strength Theory
or Jack I can't look into Jack's
theories without getting a haircut a
headache he said he says challenge any
of these Schmucks to debate the saati
they're all scared oh yeah right you
know so no one will debate him that's
his problem no I I'll quote what I uh
what I was told once that uh Richard
Dawkins said when he was as to challenge
so and he doesn't believe in evolution
he says I could see how that would be an
outstanding addition to your CV but you
can understand how it would be an
absolutely horrendous one for mine right
so Jack's completely you know no no
one's going to debate him no one's going
to because actually because they want be
associated with him they don't want to
be associated with him they don't take
him Ser I actually joke I say like
somebody comes up with it because
actually Eric Weinstein's called me up a
lot recently asking about like my
thoughts on grush and you know I
actually haven't done my due diligence
on I've been so busy the last couple
weeks but it's something I'm going to
have time maybe even talk to grush at
some point but um but I always ask Eric
or whoever I talk to or they have some
new Theory I say What's the sarfati
number you know like how far away from
complete abject unfalsifiability just
like I C there first I came up with this
and just the kind of grandiosity that
people like Jack will have and there's
many of them I emails from them every
day um you know Professor keing you're
wrong everybody's wrong I'm right let me
come on The Talk podcast um Let me let
me write a paper with you I'm not good
in math I mean Jack's probably good in
math but uh they'll say I'm not good in
math but if you help me out we share the
Nobel Prize and you know and for you
know I don't blame these people for
having passion about these different
phenomena but look if I asked you you
know Dan I said to you look which is
more important let's say let's say grush
is or there there is something and I
don't know I actually don't know which
because I think you're you do an
outstanding J you don't really kind of
tip your hand at what you truly believe
you're not dogmatic you're kind of
curious you want to hear the answer and
you know for me if I asked you just
point blank I said let's say grush is
right what do you think is the
technology that allowed these spacecraft
to get here he's claiming as far I
understand it he hasn't seen and you
please correct me wrong because I don't
follow this nearly as close as you do
but he's claiming that there are people
in the government our US government that
have covered up the landing of of
spacecraft with bodies inside with some
type of biologics he's called them in
Congressional testimony um um I've had
on Ryan Graves on my podcast who's a
former F-18 Pilot We he been here too
yeah yeah and he's great he's a very
sweet guy and I believe you know he's
Earnest in his mission what he's trying
to accomplish um and he hasn't said
though you know he he he did never said
that he saw these craft these spheres
and exactly he said that he knows the
pilots and they would not only see them
they'd see them every day every
deployment so and fraver claims he saw
this Tic Tac let's just say they're all
real there's some kernel of Truth God
tells you here Danny boom they're true
there's Tic Tacs there's crash saucers
there's biologics there's cubes with
spher and spheres with
cubes what if I asked you Danny what was
the technology that was more important
to those aliens to get here was it
String Theory or was it Metallurgy what
would you say it is what technology
enabled it more the if you just had a
guess was it something like string
theory or was it something like
Metallurgy I would say something like
Metallurgy yeah I mean it's much more
practical right there's nothing about
String Theory necessarily that involves
anything that's a necessary condition
for those aliens to get here and yet you
have people like Jack and like others
that you need this warp drive and you
need this Theory of physics and Eric's
theory of geometric Unity is wrong
because
this to a to answer this question
usually presupposes the fact that these
distances are enormous which is true I
mean these distances are enormous but
the age of the universe is also quite
enormous right so if you imagine um that
these craft have been traveling if they
exist and I'm not saying I actually
don't think they exist right you know so
so i' rather you know kind of defend
that but I think to be an intellectual
and to be honest you have to say look
let's give the other side Steelman the
your opponent's argument and see if that
sharpens up your own so from my
perspective when people result as Dave
gush has that these things are Holograms
and they travel at the you know fast and
the speed of light and they can
manipulate SpaceTime I've heard him when
he was on Joe Rogan speculating about
this tying in these loose Notions of
quantum mechanics and relativity and
warp drives and and all these other
things he's a physicist too isn't he
grush no no I think I thought he had
agree in physics he might have a
bachelor's degree or something that
doesn't mean he's a physicist yeah and
he's not a pilot I mean not um and I
don't think that those things
necessarily like fraver oh you're
doubting a US Navy veteran I'm like he
has more bigger balls than I do but it
doesn't mean he's like better Observer
and analytic when it comes to data
analysis he did an eyewitness thing you
know probably most courts you know
eyewitness reports are replat with being
completely erronous Mis misinterpreted
you know they have famous studies where
there's like the Stanford said there's a
gorilla dribbling a b basketball like
between all these other people and
you're just counting how many times
somebody dribbles a basketball and a
gorilla goes to nobody notices the
gorilla I mean the the fact that human
beings are not considered as reliable as
other forms of evidence in many
situations leads me to say that like
yeah I'm just as qualified I'm not again
I don't have the balls that David fraver
Ryan Graves have my friend Ariel
kleinerman I've had on all these guys I
have it on David frer uh Alex Dietrich I
mean I'm big balls whatever she has big
ovaries I'm not I don't have the courage
I didn't have the the physical mental
abilities to be a pilot at their level I
fly little Cessnas around but um okay I
stipulate that but does that mean that
you just trust whatever they say I mean
are we in The Stance are we going to
take the stance that someone in the
government is to be trusted I mean I
always thought the government is to be
is to be suspicious of right they
covered up Roswell they covered up all
these things C assassinated so you can't
have it both ways I mean at some point
you have to look and say what the data
tell us right now and I'm always
surprised on my channel how many people
just assume that I'm working for big
astronomy or there's some like you know
conspiracy that I'm a part of that like
because I am skeptical of the existence
look I'm I'm be honest I'm skeptical not
only of the existence of alien
technology I'm fairly suspicious of the
existence of alien life which is a
prerequisite for alien intelligence and
Technology right